pour reprendre une analogie c'est un
petit peu comme l'avion c'est à dire que
l'avion la plupart des gens comprennent
pas comment y vole et donc ont peur de
prendre l'avion sauf que l'avion il
entre vous et vos vacances personne va
vous obliger à le prendre
donc si vous voulez aller en vacances
vous forcer à le prendre les gens
comprennent pas l'utilité du nucléaire
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on ressent dans
dans ce débat là ah oui mais c'est un
débat de société pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas autre chose
et parce qu'il ya pas autre chose la
norvège fait de l'hydroélectricité parce
qu'elle est là ses capacités là
l'allemagne a fait du charbon parce
qu'elle avait du charbon si on avait eu
du charbon en france on n'aurait pas
développer autant le nucléaire parce que
le charbon ça coûte rien et puis ce
n'est pas de potentiel renouvelables
pour atteindre l'autosuffisance qu'il y
à il ya un potentiel qui est qui et qui
est limité et de toute façon le l'invité
la france c'est quand même plus de 60
millions d'habitants il reste une
industrie
on a des besoins incompressibles même
quand il n'ya pas de vent même quand ya
pas de soleil le pic de demande
électrique en france à 19 heures en
hiver à 19 heures il ya jamais de soleil
et le vent il n'a pas nécessairement
d'opéra les pics de consommation sur
sous les anticyclones des grosses vagues
de froid il ya d'autant moins de vent et
donc le choix il vient de là
on the deaf ne voudrais pas construire d
une boîte privée ne chercherait pas à
construire des choses qui ne sont pas
rentables et qui ne sont pas utiles s'il
y'avait france ait envie d'avoir 400
éoliennes n'ont plus à paris pour faire
lâcher un petit exemple en 2018 la
source d'énergie au niveau mondial qui a
le plus progressé c'est le gaz et les
deux tiers de l'augmentation de la
consommation énergétique au niveau
mondial ce sont des combustibles
fossiles
si les énergies renouvelables
électriques et est si intéressante que
ça est-ce que les gens continueraient à
faire ça au bout d'un moment il ya quand
même de la logique
[Musique]